Grand Paris Express est mort vive le
nouveau Grand Paris Jean-Marc ko a donc
tranché mercredi oui le projet de
transport de banlieu à banlieu initié
par Nicolas Sarkozi verra bien le jour
mais il coûtera plus cher et les travaux
seront plus longs dans le détail 200 km
de ligne vont voir le jour ainsi que 72
gares le coût global est de 29,5
milliard d'euros contre 20 milliards
initialement annoncé le financement
n'est pas totalement finalisé il se fera
par une redistribution de certaines
taxes touchant les entreprises et aussi
par une contribution de plusieurs mil
des collectivités locales mais le
Premier ministre a aussi évoqué la
possibilité d'augmenter les amendes
forfaitaires de stationnement de 17 à 35
€. concernant le département des
Yvelines des ajustements ont été opérés
sur le projet initial l'ancienne ligne
verte a été baptisée ligne 18 elle
reliera Versailles chantier à massipa
lesau en passant par 550 ans en Yveline
et ne sera achevé qu'en 2030
l'aménagement sera plus léger un métro
sur pneus un tram-train et un métro
aérien cette ligne 18 permettra en tout
cas de desservir sa clé et appeler à
devenir un pôle de compétitivité
incontournable avec ses entreprises et
ses centres de recherche et de formation
l'enjeu est de taille avec ses
réalisations le gouvernement entend
permettre à la région de rivaliser avec
les principaux pôles économiques
mondiaux en réduisant les temps de
déplacement